[Music]  the mighty  papavas  a fearless warrior in a world without  sight  everyone close to you always ends up  suffering  [Music]  now it's your turn brother  i swore i would never return here took  my  [Music]  i need to daughter out where he's hiding  here  [Music]  what do you see  a shift in the world  we are chosen to usher in a new world  i carry within me a child born with  god's gift  of vision  [Applause]  sight will return and the first nation  to harness its powers  will dominate the world  you're declaring war on the greatest  military force in the world  this is not our fight if we walk away  thousands of people will die  [Music]  i know this enemy i was this enemy  they fight to enslave we fight for  freedom  i say we open our gate right now  [Music]  and welcome them to hell  there are weapons more powerful than  sorts  they look the key to our future  welcome home bubba  [Music]  you